moi ce que je propose déjà c'est de
commencer par allumer votre four ok
alors tu peut allumer ton four à 170 je
vais faire pareil moi de mon côté
alors ce que je vous propose en allumer
le four on va commencer notre mélange
c'est un mélange hyper simple 1 on va
déjà prendre nos tops tout d'abord on va
prendre un cul-de-poule tous cas plus
ordinaires et je vais les et je vais
mélanger deux dans mes éléments sec
c'est-à-dire ma poudre d'amande mon
sucre et la farine
déjà dans un premier temps une cuisse
une grosse ligne arras ça c'est quoi
écoute moi j'ai une tasse à café
j'ai mis dans une tasse à café j'ai pesé
ça fait à peu près d une demi tasse à
café sucre poudre d'amande farine
ok c'est mélanger pour toi c'est
mélanger pour moi jusque là c'est pas
très compliqué là je vais rajouter
maintenant face au ca seras jamais
compliqué n'est pas dans la
démonstration technique on est juste
pour se régaler donc la crème fraîche
là je t'assure non pardon pardon je dis
une bêtise on va mettre les oeufs avant
ouais c'est mieux 2e entier ouais ça va
aller là jusque là on se lie un au
casier et on va rajouter seulement 2
jaunes d'oeufs jambes
voilà on va garder les blancs tour quand
on fera ne s'est pas mouillé dans lequel
on rajoutera vêtements et un deuxième
jaune je rappelle que nous sommes en
train de réaliser un plat outils
framboise regarde avec deux pâtissiers
bien coureurs ont dérivé du clafoutis
parce que j'élimine ouais y'a pas tout
le temps de la poudre d'amandes donc le
foot y'a pas se raconter l'histoire
non non non alors un appareil qui dans
la lnah cookies de prison
moi je pense que j'ai pas fait de
victime j'ai pas non plus c'est un sans
faute
faut-il validé mon passage des banques
on est autant voilà moi pareil
donc là on va mélanger on va continuer
notre mélange 1 sur mélenchon on mélange
fouet mélanger
tu peut mélanger au fouet tu peut
mélanger à la maryse dumas nous que le
mélange se fait bien l'idée c'est pas
l'idée avec le poids soit toujours faire
attention de par le corpore de l'air
comme ça pour rien très bien c'est ce
qu'il faut de la crème fraîche épaisse
en fait moi j'avais peser 130 grammes
voilà et on va continuer le mélange ce
que je vous propose c'est de voiliers je
vais prendre un peu de beurre comme ça
qui sont pas dans la recette c'est juste
pour chemise et un peu mon moule il te
reste un peu de beurre quand même pour
ça je prends mon moule comme ça et je
viens badigeonnez un fonds de bear
dessus bon alors moi je veux un tout
petit peu plus légèrement toi mais comme
tu le fais avec la main c'est plus
difficile de mesurer moi je fais qu'un
pinceau tu vois comment
voilà donc là j'ai mis mon d'heure
maintenant je vais mettre une
une demi tasse à café de sucre moi je
mets de la cassonade parce que je
préfère
en fait ça va ça va donner en fait ça ce
qui va former des petites croûtes à
l'extérieur du duc la faute il qui est
sympa quand même à la dégustation
donc la voyez j'ai vu ma cassonade et je
verrai la balade est comme ça tout
autour de moules d'accord alors je vais
essayer de faire aussi bien donc
et puis on essaye
nos maîtres la cassonade tout vas-y
vas-y je te laisse faire merci vous
pouvez utiliser n'importe quel mode
ouais d'accord oui bah voila moi j'ai
avec un moule à tarte donc bah je fais
avec ce que j'ai alors c'est bien un
sucre la cassonade et ben oui
effectivement
ok alors là par contre voyez je vais
avec mes doigts en fait juste enlevé
juste le dernier les derniers
millimètres en eau du moule pour éviter
que ça brûle avec le four et que ça
fasse après c'est chiant détaillé donc
avec le pouce comme ça je passe vraiment
j'ai sera là pour vous épauler d'accord
on nettoie comme ça vient donner un
petit à petit liseré comme ça oui très
bien dont on fait une petite finition au
point et on enlève rien à petit la
petite île israël finition c'est la
gamme touch
ouais ok donc maintenant on va
s'intéresser à nos fruits dans la
rhubarbe déjà un couteau ok équipements
magnifique couteau en bois un grand
couteau non petit couteau à tous at il
déclaré un tout petit couteau
bon en fait on n'a pas besoin de se
tarir les déjà il paie coupé épluchés
par donc ça nous voilà bien j'ai plus ma
rhubarbe donc en fait pour le touché la
rhubarbe tir d'un côté et on enlève la
peau comme ça on roule à je vais prendre
mon couteau et émincer mais mais mais
rhubarbe grossièrement d'appât je fais
des courses un morceau à peu près d'un
centimètre comme toi pour te très bien
pour m'adapter tu vois c'est quand même
dingue non en fait je m'adapte fait que
m'adapter bravo merci hein donc avec
cette rue brown qu'on va mettre cru on
aurait vu la peau chez un petit peu dans
son jus avec la peau qui reste bien
rouge et qui donne de la couleur avec un
petit trailer de ranger pour donner
davantage de goût mais ton challenge
était de faire une recette en moins
d'une heure
voilà tu vois je voulais disposer au
fond du moule comme ça donc j'ai utilisé
un bâton ont convaincu compter sur la
cuisson du clafoutis pour cuir
légèrement nous rus bat être car est un
peu craquante lesquels donnent un peu de
d'acidité en fait l'idée c'est que
l'appareil il est un peu sucré il a un
peu rond et avec l'acidité de la
framboise et d'allevard savard équilibré
c'est bon ça quand vous le dites moi
j'ai pas de gp de rhubarbe rejet du kiwi
essayer quand même de choisir des fruits
qui ont une certaine acidité une
certaine fraîcheur pour venir casser un
peu le suc la crème fraîche et la
rondeur de tous ces ingrédients très
bien est unitaire de chef pâtissier
ok ok donc c'est une rue bar de tout ce
qu'il ya de plus classique il ya des
rumeurs qui existe des rues de barbes
blanches rouges qui sont un peu plus
qualitatif aulas j'ai fait avec la
rhubarbe que j'ai trouvé en bas et j'ai
trouvé quoi et moi c'était la rhubarbe
que j'avais surgelés alors votre set
allait fait pour une classe outils pour
quatre mois j'ai un petit moule qui fait
un peu près 2 donc je vais pas utiliser
j'en ferai un deuxième comme ça parce
que parce que parce que j'ai un petit
boulot mais normalement vous dans la
mule pour 4 vous devriez on met
davantage que moi très bien donc là je
vais coulé sur mairie va donc une partie
de mon appareil une partie seulement
dollars dont trois petits pour tous m
oui donc moi je vais tout est en fait il
faut remonter à moitié en moitié du
monde ce qui nous donne un truc un peu
près dans ce but-là toit d'un moment tu
devrais tout maintenant j'ai tout mis
dedans et ça donne ça ok bon ton boule
il est pas pour cathy les pour 6 oui
donc ça va être un petit peu moins effet
bas je te propose de quitter là il est
médiatement on voit là t'as pas respecté
les consignes
ces mornes dominé le conseil a voté
ouais c'est ça tu vois les mémés merbah
moines sont complètement immergé parce
que vous voyez là d'accord oui alors en
pleine journée qui sont pas tout à fait
émerger bon c'est pas grave allait alors
là maintenant on va mettre les
framboises 1 il faut pas se faire
attention on va juste les déposer en
surface comme ça ils vont s'enfoncer
lentement pendant la cuisson vous allez
voir ça mais les idées pour que le le le
clafoutis soit joli à voir
c'est que il faut qu'on les voit un
petit peu les framboises sera assorti
d'une fois donc il faut juste les poser
parsemer un petit peu et les poser bon
elle est chassée
est-ce que je peux parfois les poser sur
des morceaux de rhubarbe
il faut quand même qu'ils aient une la
base d'accords dans l'appareil tu vois
moi je suis habité entre très bien vu la
configuration
ok alors voilà maintenant on vient
déposer nos framboise entre nos mains la
prochaine fois la prochaine fois tu
prendras un moule de de six personnes
deux cas de perte de six personnes
maintenant oui bon t'as pris dans 2 4
c'est quoi comme sur malika personnes
bah oui ray barbee alors on me demande
si les fruits surgelés vont rendre du
jus il ya de chances oui mais la
rhubarbe la rhubarbe aussi var ont du
jus c'est pour cela on a fait un
appareil qui qui absorbe quand même un
peu tout ça d'accord on va là-bas
absorber bah tu l'as dit freud ynet pose
la même question est-ce que ça va rendre
du juba oui ça va rendre un peu de jus
mais yann on me demande que tu que tu
montres la façon dont tu disposes les
fruits parce qu on ne voit pas et tout
le monde est très impatient évidemment
pour pouvoir comparer bien sûr que je
fais et avec ce qu'ils jouent mais bon
je pense que là ça va être une heure de
vérité absolument délicate pour moi est
ce que vous voyez bien waouh
ah ouais on voit bien que les framboises
sont superbes
et oui j'ai pas fini je vais rajouter
quelques petits morceaux de rhubarbe à
ses fins on trie les frondaisons tu en
voilà
votre prochain donc là
petite immersion dans mon four alive en
prendre ok alors il est temps de cuisson
en fait ça dépend
à chaque fois de votre four parce qu'il
ya chaque fois en sa propre vérité
et puis la taille du moule que vous avez
utilisé moi je dirais que c'est environ
15 minutes après avoir activement parce
que là on est sur lui sur une recette
qui va ce que malgré tout d'en adapter
chez chacun avec un four différent chez
chacun donc moi j'ai je table sur 4 15
minutes environ et on est toujours à 170
2 2 on avait près chauffer en début de
week-end n'a pas répété on a reconstitué
le four à 170 degrés au début de la
recette et maintenant nous environ une
quinzaine de minutes
commencez à regarder au bout de 12
minutes peut-être que ça sera cuit avant
ça dépend vraiment de l'épaisseur du
moule est d'accord voilà parce que tu
vois quand tu touches avec la main si ça
colle tu peut planter un couteau dans le
centre du gâteau pour voir si ton
couteau ressort est nickel ou pas on à
faire ça et puis et puis là tu vas te
donner une indication
c'est donc un soutien écrits ou pas il
est il est un peu claires je te dirais
bien de remonter un peu ton four pour
colorer un petit peu je le trouve un peu
pâlichon et lavande on peut remplacer
par la farine dans sa part contre sauf
si tu verra t on bientôt je te
déconseille de remplacer la bande par la
farine tu peux remplacer par de la
poudre de noisettes si tu fais surtout
attention la coloration ne compte pas
augmenter
il a un peu plus osé encore se mettait
sur tulle a allumé ok je vous montre le
mien où vous l'été si si si si si si je
viens regardez on voit ce clafoutis de
yann couvreur
bah écoute il est pas beau il me tient
vraiment aussi beau si ce n'est plus oh
comme c'est gentil regarde donc vous
chez vous j'espère que vous avez réussi
votre clafoutis amboise rhubarbe
je regarde regarde juste ajouter un peu
de sucre et glace juste pour la finition
tu mens magnifique moi je n'avais pas de
sucre glace mais si chez vous vous avez
du sucre glace et bien vous faites ce
petit geste de finition pour votre
clafoutis que vous n'hésiterez pas à
prendre en photo et a publié avec le
hashtag cuisine est confiné c'est